Il y eut une époque où les hommes vivaient
sans argent, mais certainement pas sans richesse.
Une richesse alimentaire, grâce à l'agriculture,
une richesse de matières premières luxueuses,
grâce aux échanges de sel et de pierres
comme le jade, l'obsidienne, la variscite.
C'était en Europe, au Néolithique, entre
le 5ème et le 3ème millénaire. Ces sociétés,
qui pratiquaient l'agriculture et stockaient
leurs denrées alimentaires étaient riches,
une richesse qui pouvait même être ostentatoire,
celle qui se montre, qui s'expose. Par quels moyens ?
Et bien, les menhirs, ces pierres dressées qui ornent
les paysages de nombreuses régions en sont
un exemple. On connaît beaucoup de sites
dans le monde où sont implantés des menhirs :
en Asie du Sud-Est, dans le Pacifique, en Afrique
mais, plus proche de nous, il y a la façade
atlantique de l'Europe et plus précisément
le département du Morbihan en Bretagne.
Et c'est là où je vous emmène.
Les menhirs sont des mégalithes
Littéralement, des gros blocs de pierre.
Un type de construction
propre à certaines sociétés que l'on
appelle donc des sociétés mégalithiques.
Il y a deux grandes catégories de monuments.
La première est celle des menhirs, pierres
dressées de plus ou moins grande taille,
isolées ou groupées en cercle ou en
alignements. La seconde catégorie comprend
les divers types de dolmens dont on sait aujourd'hui
que ce sont des tombeaux qui recevaient plusieurs
sépultures. Si on arrive à comprendre
le rôle de ces dolmens sans trop de difficulté,
celui des menhirs est plus compliqué et
c'est pourquoi j'ai voulu me concentrer
uniquement sur ce cas.
Au début du 5ème millénaire et en l'espace  de 10 générations, la Bretagne se couvre
de ces monuments spectaculaires : de très
grands menhirs, parfois gravés de motifs
signalent des tumulus. Les tumulus sont des
masses de terre et de pierre dans lesquels
on aménage de petites chambres funéraires.
Dans ces chambres, on retrouve des objets
de valeurs : des haches polies, souvent
nombreuses, qui témoignent d'échanges
entre les populations alpines et bretonnes
mais aussi des anneaux de pierre et des perles
de variscite. La variscite est une turquoise d'un vert pâle
provenant de Galice en Espagne. Dans ce cas
là, les menhirs de plusieurs mètres de
haut sont un indice dans le paysage et permettent
d'indiquer l'emplacement de la tombe.
Si l'art paléolithique se méritait,
car il fallait pour admirer les peintures
rupestres aller au fond des cavernes, l'art
néolithique lui, se montre ! A Locmariaquer,
c'est un menhir brisé de 20 m de haut
et 280 t que l'on a transporté sur des dizaines de km.
Autre phénomène troublant,
ce sont les alignements de Carnac : près
de 3000 menhirs! Le Morbihan est d'après
les cartes, une région littéralement couverte de mégalithes !
On s'interroge souvent sur les moyens techniques
à ces époques pour dresser un menhir. En
réalité c'est pas ce qui posait le
plus de problèmes : une masse d'hommes,
des cordes, une levée de terre et un peu
d'expérience suffisent. Le plus intéressant
est en fait de saisir les raisons qui poussent
les hommes à se réunir pour construire
de tels monuments de leur plein gré, ou
pas d'ailleurs. En tout cas une chose est
sûre, il faut nous interroger sur le mode
de financement de ces constructions. Qui commande,
qui paye ?
Le mégalithisme ne serait-il
pas le début d'une démonstration économique,
où les bâtisseurs agissent sous la contrainte,
obéissant à un chef puissant qui donne les ordres?
C'est l'opinion de plusieurs chercheurs,
qui ont vu dans ces constructions l'émergence
d'un pouvoir fort. Mais ce n'est pas l'avis
de tout le monde.
J'ai donc envie de vous présenter ici  l'hypothèse de
l'anthropologue Alain Testart qui m'a
particulièrement séduite.
Il faut dire  d'abord que le mégalithisme apparaît
presque en même temps que l'agriculture
-5000 pour l'agriculture en Bretagne et
-4700 pour les premiers mégalithismes. Donc moins
de 3 siècles les séparent, ce qui est
peu à l'échelle archéologique de ces
temps anciens.
Testart rappelle que le début de l'agriculture
marque aussi le début de la richesse. Les
pratiques agricoles ont bouleversé l'économie
des chasseurs-cueilleurs. Ils apprennent à partir
de cette période à stocker leurs aliments,
et qui dit stock dit richesse. Mais la richesse
pour faire quoi ? A cette époque on ne
paye pas sa nourriture, on ne touche pas de
salaire et les produits du quotidien sont
fabriqués pour la plupart par leurs utilisateurs.
La richesse ne peut donc être dépensée
ni dans l'achat de parcelles ni de coupés
cabriolets, tout simplement parce que personne n'en vend.
Dans ce contexte, les menhirs et tombes mégalithiques
servaient sans doute, aux hommes illustres,
à montrer leur richesse. Ceux qui pouvaient
s'offrir de tels édifices étaient ceux
qui avaient pu réunir et entretenir une
main d’œuvre le temps des travaux. Mais
j'en reviens à la question déjà posée :
comment réunir autant d'hommes et comment
les récompenser sans salaire ?
Pour Testart, il est plus vraisemblable que
les menhirs et autres monuments de ce type
aient été érigés lors de fêtes plutôt
que sous la contrainte. Pourquoi la fête ?
Et bien parce, dans une société sans salaire,
une fête et un repas conséquent sont une
manière de rémunérer, de remercier. On
y vient parce qu'on sait qu'on y sera
nourri et on travaille pour celui qui nous
nourrit.
C'est la charge de réciprocité.
Ça vous paraît tiré par les cheveux cette
histoire ?
Pourtant quelques témoignages oraux de populations
pratiquant le mégalithisme nous laisse penser
cela : dans la tribu des Kélabites à Bornéo, on
a recueilli le témoignage d'un homme qui
prévoit d'élever une grande tombe et cela
se passe un peu avant sa mort. Pour cela il
rassemble toutes ses économies c'est-à-dire de la nourriture, et en particulier du riz
pour offrir une grande fête
à tous ceux qui participeront à l'ouvrage.
Une fois le monument érigé, cet homme
espère que sa réputation de richesse se
perpétue, qu'elle traverse les âges.
Je viens de vous livrer quelques pistes de
réflexion pour les grands menhirs dressés,
mais que dire des alignements de pierres
sur plusieurs km que l'on peut voir à Carnac ?
En réalité, on n'en sait rien, tout
ce qu'on peut dire, c'est que ce n'est
pas un cimetière. Sous les pierres, aucun corps.
Pour tenter d'y voir plus clair, il faut aller voir ailleurs, chez les vivants.
Dans
le Sud de l'Ethiopie, deux sociétés
celle des Konso et celle des Gewada dressent
des menhirs. Pour les Konso, les menhirs sont
placés à la suite d'un exploit, la victoire
d'une bataille par exemple, ou pour honorer
le mérite d'un homme valeureux en plaçant
la pierre directement sur sa tombe. Et chez
les Gewada, peuple voisin des Konso, lorsqu'un
membre du clan meurt, on creuse sa tombe dans
son champ sur laquelle on dresse une pierre.
Puis on vient en dresser une seconde dans
un lieu collectif mais cette fois pour rappeler
symboliquement son appartenance au clan. Ainsi,
des alignements de pierres se forment sans
sépulture.
L'exemple le plus caractéristique est
le site de Chelba Tutitti, toujours en Éthiopie
fouillé par l'équipe de Roger Joussaume
qui a révélé à proximité d'une
tombe recouverte d'un tumulus des
centaines de stèles alignées.
Le tumulus jouerait ici le rôle de point
de départ pour toutes ces stèles successives
car c'est la sépulture d'un ancêtre
héroïque auquel on voue un culte. On vient
donc déposer symboliquement ses descendants
morts auprès de lui sous la forme d'un menhir.
Bon alors je fabule peut-être complètement,
mais après tout c'est le rôle de l'archéologie
de proposer des scénarios : est-ce que
Carnac ne pourrait pas être aussi un gigantesque
lieu de mémoire de 4 km
où des clans sont venus pendant des générations
rappeler leur appartenance à une famille, à une société ?
Les alignements de Carnac,
c'était peut-être ce qui faisait qu'on
se sentait morbihannais il y a 6000 ans.
Je vous l'accorde, toutes ces notions sont complexes : culte des ancêtres, représentation
symboliques,
monuments aux morts, appartenance à un clan, richesse ostentatoire surtout
pour de simples pierres levées.
Mais après, tout, nous aussi, nous avons bien notre Panthéon.
Ah c'est sûr que ce serait beaucoup plus facile de dire que ce sont les extra-terrestres...